للاستمتاع بعطلتك المقبله دعك من الكاميرا
الضخمه المكلفه ففي هذه الايام كل ما عليك
اقتنائه هو الهاتف الذكي الكثير من الناس
يستخدمون هواتفهم الذكيه لالتقاط الصور
المهمه اثناء قضائهم اجازه مع الاصدقاء
والعائله فهناك تطبيقات كثيره تمكنك من
تحسين نوعيه
الصوره دعنا نقول ان لديك اطلاله رائعه
وتريد اظهار كل التفاصيل فهناك تطبيق يسمى
بانوراما 36 الذي يتيح لك الصوره والمحيط
باكمله تلقائيا يتم جمع كافه التفاصيل في
الصوره لتعطيك اطلاله بانوراميه رائعه
وهنا يظهر دور هذا التطبيق الذي يتيح لك
التقاط الصوره واضافه مجموعه كبيره من
المنقيات او ما يسمى بالفلتر وارسالها الى
اصدقائك ولتحرير الصور وبشكل فوري وسريع
هناك تطبيق يسمى سنابس وايضا تستطيع تغيير
التباين والسطوع والتشبع والعديد من
الميزات الاخرى وبمجرد الانتهاء من تحرير
الصوره يمكنك ارسالها بعده نقرات
فقط كما يمكن اضافه رائحه للبطاقه
البريديه بحيث يمكن للشخص الاخر المستقبل
ان يشم رائحتها بمجرد لمسها مما يثير
اهتمام الجميع